Hello, everybody.
Hello.
I am alive.
Um, oh my god.
Okay, I fucked up.
I fucked up.
Okay, so.
Oh, so, um, let me tell you about today's schedule.
so um so yes no after the stream we're going to go straight
to another stream because um I saw that tempo he has he you
know tempo is literally like the main apex legends
tournament organizer for like every tournament in apex so I
saw tempo on Monday I was like oh hey quiet up I was like
I thought it says July 20th because the sign-ups showed up
on Monday.
So, I was like, all right.
I'm thinking, I'm thinking, oh, yeah.
That Apex Legends tournament that got announced on Monday
will be next month.
I thought it says July 29th because usually I thought,
usually it's like organized way ahead of time.
So, like, every time, usually in the past when there's
sign-ups, Right off this week, by the way, so
Because, you know how I found out it was today?
Like, I think, like, two to three days, I think, like, two
days ago?
Yeah, it was two days ago.
I was, like, messaging my staff members.
I was like, hey, do I have anything on July 29th?
I was like, hey, I want to make sure I don't overlap with
anything on July 29th July 29th and then they're like yokey
this says June this is tomorrow I was like wait what
they're like this because like one of my staff members is
like uh Asia and then I have another that's like EU and
they're like yokey this is tomorrow because like for them
it's tomorrow So they're like, that's tomorrow.
I was like, no, it's July.
They're like, no, it's June.
And I'm like, it's June?
So I was like, oh, fuck.
Okay, it's, oh, it's June.
It's literally today.
Okay.
So, so I was just like, oh, fuck.
It's June 29th.
It's not July 29th.
So, all right.
Anyway, this is, this is my, I don't know.
Temple usually when he puts up a sign-up sheet, the
tournament isn't this week.
It's usually like, like in two to three weeks.
So I, in my head, I was like, I need you to know that hot
and seek Nokia shit.
We, we were signed up like two months ago for this.
that the Nokia had and seek thing like I was signed up to
that thing two months ago before it happened so like I in my
head I was like there's no way it's this way there's no way
anyway I appreciate temple for inviting me hey not so
Deadpool thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
thank you new model still a new skin suit still illiterate
still the goat never changed okay thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you dark blade thank you for the super
chat thank you thank Thank you.
Don't eat just like the dragoons.
Can't fucking read.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway.
So I was just like.
Oh shit.
It's today.
Technically.
So this is my schedule.
I need you guys to.
Okay.
I need you guys to know.
This is what my schedule is like today.
So this.
Then whatever.
it's time for that other thing the apex thing we go straight
to that by the way i haven't touched apex since the last
invitational that i was part of which i mean i did try to
warm up like today i did two warm-up games i was like that's
good enough um and in tempos in the sign-up sheet for the
for the tournament they're like what rank are you like
what's your highest rank i put diamond Because at that
point, I was like, I don't I haven't touched the game in
long ass time At least just considered me diamond level at
that point
Anyway Anyway, as I was saying After that, I have like a
little intermission Until I have to go to Avcon I have to do
Avcon, which is the Adelaide convention is like we go around
Artist Alley at Avcon, and then after going around Artist
Alley at Avcon, we're going to the paddle, and after doing
the paddle, we're gonna be doing meet and greets, and after
meet and greets, I sleep, and after I sleep, we do the
Doakami paddle, which is at 7.30 a.m.
my time.
Pono, thank you for the 10 gifts and shifts, thank you,
thank you.
So my Doakami paddle is tomorrow at 7.30 a.m., and then
after the Doakami paddle, We're going to go around the Don't
Keep Me artist, Sally.
And then after that, I die.
I pass out.
I'm like,
so that is, that is my schedule for today.
That is my schedule.
It leads all the way till the next day.
Yes, I did not schedule.
doing myself quite well today i did not i because i forgot
how to read today i literally signed up for tempo's thing
because i thought it was next month i didn't i knew it was
this week i believe i would have said yes maybe i would have
reached out to tempo and be like hey i want to join um
anyway but it's gonna be a blast like yesterday i did avcon
i was at adelaide Well, I wasn't at Adelaide.
I was virtually at Adelaide.
So I did, I was at Adelaide Avcon yesterday.
So yesterday, today's going to be day two of it.
Yesterday, we did a, we couldn't do the gaming session
because apparently the internet died or some shit or like
got fucked up during the gaming session.
So I couldn't do the gaming with the dragoons yesterday.
karaoke and meet and greens oh my god karaoke there was no
feedback there was no like audio feedback or anything so I I
had no I so like I was like uh for those who were like no
FOMO anyway I'll I'll talk to you guys a bit about the
abcott it was so funny so I had no audio feedback it was
like literally my very first like karaoke slash concert uh
for it and it was so funny because I because since I had no
audio feedback I was like thumbs up if it's okay
because I can't hear what's going on so I was just like give
me a thumbs up if everything's okay it's all the chakus
you're giving me thumbs up I was like alright cool sweet
okay
there was no yeah Yeah, so I had no audio feedback.
At first, I had no visual feedback.
And then one of the technician guys, like, got their phone.
Because we're all in this, like, Discord channel.
They got their phone and then turned their camera on on
their phone.
So I could, like, I was, like, watching, like, what's going
on, on, like, somebody's phone.
Because there's no camera on the stage.
So I was just, like, let's see what's going on.
And the guy was just bringing their phone and walking around
with their phone just to show you what's going on.
funny netpers thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you many sound guy can't save you now thank you for the uh
super chat thank you thank you it was really funny um
anyways i actually for those who weren't there um i saw
there was photos going around in some of the recordings i
had exclusive videos made just for like the karaoke concert
thing because you know i'm 2d because I'm not it's not like
a 3d thing it was it was 30 minutes and uh my events manager
was like I was like asking my because I've never done the
karaoke thing before I've never done like singing at a
convention before like live so I was like uh to my events
manager I was like how long how many songs do I have to do
for like 30 minutes and then my events manager was like oh
it's like five songs and I was like, all right, three songs.
I was like, okay, three songs.
And then I'm going to pad it out with like half a pad of it.
I'm going to just talk.
I was like, all right, I'm pretty sure I could do three
songs in 30 minutes and just like talk the rest of it.
And so every, every in between songs, I was just like
talking and i'm like padding out the time slot i made it in
30 minutes i got it correct okay i i like estimated the time
perfectly okay anyway those videos i'm gonna be using it for
anime expo too because like i mean paid for the video so i
might as well like it paid for those the the the visuals for
the karaoke so i'm gonna use it for anime expo as well and i
mean i see I have to sing, like, an hour.
And then after that, and then after that, the stream people
might be able to see it.
I don't know.
Maybe in the next karaoke, I hate 100K.
It depends.
It really, it really depends.
I want to make it more sure, like, because, like, I guess,
like, if you're going to a convention, you get, like, the
exclusive sneak peek before I actually use it on stream.
But that's, that was basically, karaoke and then like the
meet and greet I went an hour over time because there were
so many Australian dragoons I was so surprised um there were
people that were not from Australia that came to the abcon
and I'm just like guys it's a world tool don't worry I might
come over I saw one of the dragoons here um who literally
flew from the US to go to abcon to see me and I was I don't
want to call you out.
I mean, you can, like, reveal yourself if you want to.
But there was, like, dragons that flew from the U.S.
And there was dragons from, like, there was, like, dragons
from Japan that came over, like, Japan, Singapore, Malaysia,
Hong Kong.
Like, they were like, yeah, I was like, well, because, like,
okay, there was one.
I think, like, it was, like, an American accent.
an American accent uh was like I mean to greet and I was
just like that's not Australian where you doing I was like
what are you doing here that's not an Australian accent
and they're like I flew from America I was like oh my god
what the fuck wait I was like wait a minute it's from
Australian Trillion Dragoons how did you get here
um um but it was it was actually uh it was actually crazy i
was so happy to meet all the dragons like i said i went like
um i think like when the first guy came over for the meet
and greet they were like there's a lot of people because
it's free the meet and greet was free like i don't earn
anything from it at best i earn from the there's like
exclusive merch at the convention some uh collector's card
or something that's like the only thing and even then i
don't i think I think or 400 I don't remember like because
it's like limited amount so like if we sold everything I
would make like around 200 or 400 I think but like the uh I
just wanted the like just something a little bit like a
little momentum of like conventions and stuff of something
from the conventions and stuff um um but like uh what was I
gonna say uh but yes anyway uh the And it was just like, you
just line up.
That's really it for Avcon.
And basically, when the first Dragoon was there for the Mean
and Greed, I was like, how many people are there?
And he was like, oh, like 50.
I was like, what the fuck?
And this was day one.
There's going to be a day two for Mean and Greed.
And then they're like, there's like around like 50.
And then they like took the webcam and like, like showed me
the line.
And I was like, oh my God, how's there?
It's Adelaide.
I'm sorry for people who live in Adelaide.
But like, we were all, okay, you were joking with me.
You guys said it to me first.
A lot of the Adelaide Australian dragoons were like, why are
you here?
It's Adelaide.
A lot of the Australian dragoons were like, why are you
here?
Like, like, we were so weird.
They're like, I'm surprised you're here.
it was apparently this like a small city compared to um
compared to like sydney or melbourne and i was just like
well they invited me so i'm here oh my god it was more than
i don't know i don't know how many dragoons i met but i went
an hour over time because like uh when it was like supposed
to end one of the staff members like are you able to go over
time because there's like 20 plus more dragoons in line
they're like we cut it off now but like there's still 20 and
i was just like you know what you guys those 20 plus
dragoons like line up for an hour i feel so bad turning them
away after an hour so uh so i went on for longer than i
think i went on for two hours and a half i don't i don't
remember i was so tired by the end i was so after after the
meet and greet i like i don't i just i just went to bed no i
made my waiting room after the meet and greet and then i
went to bed um but it was very fun i had like a lot amazing
time i felt bad because sometimes i'm the reason why like
people okay because like i think it was like three minutes
they changed it a bit because they didn't realize how many
australian dragoons Because, like, I know, like, VTubers
don't come to Australia a lot.
Especially for, like, meet and greets and stuff.
So, like, I had a lot of Australian dragoons that were like,
Oh, my God, you were, like, the first VTuber I've ever met.
Because, like, nobody comes here.
Especially Adelaide.
I'm like, yeah, I'm here.
That's why it's a world tour.
tour i wanted to be everywhere and um um um it was really
fun though being and then being able to meet so many
dragoons and like like i said like uh one person flew from
like out they're like australian one person flew out from
outside of adelaide and they're like they like to me they're
like, I'm so tired.
I just got here today.
And then after this meet and greet, I'm flying back.
I'm like, what?
Oh my God, for me, I was like, put on a pad.
Anyway, like, one of the Australian dragons literally like
flew in on the day.
Like, they arrived in the morning.
They arrived in the morning and then they like did all the,
you know, the karaoke, the karaoke and then the meet and
greet and they're like yeah I'm flying back after this meet
and greet and I'm like oh my god oh my god thank you I felt
bad because like like majority of the the the meeting greet
it was just like me yapping and then and then the staff
members like times up I was like oh oh no I didn't let you
talk like I'm sorry I'll just be like hey And then staff,
hey, you're almost done.
And I'm like, ah!
That would be like, oh my God, what do you want to say?
I'm sorry, what do you want to say?
Um, but yeah, that was, that was basically, uh, Avcon so far
for me.
Um, but yes, it's been, it's been great so far.
Uh, definitely having a lot.
I love doing conventions because, you know, I get to see you
guys.
like I could potentially like put faces to your names and
even though like I'm gonna forget your I'm I'm not a face
person I just need you guys to know that like uh sometimes I
forget faces because I'm you know I mean I'm illiterate as
fuck so but like in the moment I get to put a face to your
name no I've actually like I've actually forgotten like
classmates faces at points too um because Like, I don't
know.
I'm just not a face person.
I'm a name person.
Not a face person.
Like, they'll be like, I'll be like, who's that?
And then I'll, and I see them.
I'm like, I still don't know who it is.
And then they'll say the name.
And I'm like, oh, that guy.
I remember him.
So I literally can't remember.
I like, I don't know.
I'm very forgetful when it comes to faces.
Okay, I realized like we're sort of like very off topic for
the first 22 minutes.
uh because we're sort of on a tight a little bit of a tight
schedule right now since we're after this we have to go
straight to the apex shit uh so behind the scenes of the
skin suit reveal um it was uh for the uh artists and the um
team the my team that's working on this we're wondering oh
what can i and cannot post uh i'll write this in the server
i know that some of you guys are watching this right now um
basically you guys even if I don't show the work that you
guys gave me um also I didn't really I didn't like save
everything so I saved everything that are behind the scenes
channel but I didn't say like look back I was so busy guys I
know the wallpapers haven't been posted the 3d models
haven't been posted the music haven't been posted guys I
can't wait to like like rest one day guys what is resting
like again guys there's there's a lot there's there's it'll
eventually just so you guys know they'll it'll eventually be
posted guys i swear to god i i swear to god it'll be posted
soon uh by the way minecraft server will be open next week
guys um we are gonna have a i'm gonna make a white list uh
in the membership post and like i'm gonna have a my uh start
white listing people um but yes the minecraft server is
finally finally gonna be up next week after so long there
was uh they actually i think they gave me did they give me a
refund i was so surprised i need to look at i need i need to
give me a second i need to look this up because i think they
actually they were like they felt really bad and they're
like we're gonna give you a refund and i was like oh my god
what this is like oh yeah they're gonna give me a partial
refund for um the server because they felt they never they
had a they were like we're so sorry like we never had to
delay a project uh for this long so then they gave me a
partial refund which version will it be a good question i'll
give you guys the they originally they were ready for this
week they were ready for the uh minecraft server this week i
was like and then i i didn't answer the message for like
four days and they're like we're ready to debut the
minecraft server this wednesday and then i did not answer
the message in four days and they're like poking me and was
like hey so like yeah what's going on and i'm like i'm sorry
I'm, I'm sorry.
I'm so tired.
I was just like, I'm sorry.
Can we do next week?
I'm so, I'm sorry.
We have to do next week now.
This week is, it's a lie.
So they're like, yeah, we can do next week.
I'm like, oh, thank God.
Oh, thank God.
so so that's why we uh i'm doing my best i am doing my best
guys so i think it's also because like i'm doing everything
i wasn't able to do in the past but then like i put
everything like like i was like the sooner the better you
know like i didn't i didn't like what's the word I didn't I
didn't like stagger stagger things I was just like bam bam
bam bam bam and all just jumbled together like everything's
just I remember like I think like three three or four months
ago they're like hey maybe you shouldn't say yes to all
these things stuff happening in June and July I was like no
I want to do it
I don't know.
This seems all really too close together.
Maybe you should, like, reject some of these.
I was like, no, I'm not rejecting.
I'm not, I'm not rejecting.
I never had a chance to do any of these things.
So I'm going to say yes to everything.
And then, and then, yeah, Doki, past Doki really fucked
over, Kuro and Doki.
Yeah.
Past Doki really did fuck over, Kuro.
and Doki, that's for sure.
That's for sure.
I did not pace myself at all.
Manny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The day where you get to actually do nothing is the real
celebration of the year.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So that's why there's a lot of things.
There's so many things happening in June and July because
there was a lot of stuff that was offered July completion
type deal or like like the events will be June the July and
then I was like yes and they're like yeah but then you have
this other thing going on too that's like the day after it
and I'm like it doesn't matter it's virtual I'll be there
yes and then and then and that's why my schedule is like
this today uh but I'm having fun I'm having fun though in
the end even though I am tired a bit okay a bit is sort of
an understatement but like I'm enjoying the moment you know
I'm enjoying the moment I'm pretty sure when I look back to
it I'll be like oh my god that was a that was a lot during
that week but like I still had a great time I got to meet my
dragoons and I got to I get to hang out with my dragoons and
that's all that matters to me uh okay anyway behind the
scenes for real uh
For real behind the scenes I need to move myself a little
bit so you can see that I got rid of like Oh shit okay
that's not it that might be a moving myself a little bit too
much Okay whoa okay give me a sec whoa sorry give me a sec I
need to adjust some stuff I'm gonna Okay I'm gonna make
another version of me real fast I'm gonna Naruto make
another version okay I should not be behind the table Guys,
I'm sorry, bartender.
I'm not here to steal your beer and alcohol.
Sorry, bartender.
Give me a sec.
I messed up.
All right, here we go.
All right.
Is this where I'm supposed to?
Okay.
Anyway, I'm going to move over here.
Sorry, I'm covering like half the chat, right?
You guys are going to see the chat like between my hair.
I'll be here.
I think that's it here.
All right.
Anyway, so you guys can see the left side where I'm going to
put some behind the scenes stuff.
Oh, I'm really tired.
Today is a long day.
Oh, all right.
Okay, so I want to show you guys this debut.
I'm not going to tell you guys like the price of everything
in the public stream.
um I finally calculated everything well I didn't calculate
everything so like um when you I do everything via PayPal so
um the thing is there's a money out in the PayPal and even
then there's like some stuff that doesn't show up because
you know like the the the skin suit the rigging and
everything that was like done month like maybe like a couple
of months ago and uh because of that it doesn't show up but
then you see money out and then i saw money out and i was
like oh my god and then there's some people that haven't
even sent me invoices yet i have some people and there's
some i haven't paid invoices yet and i was like oh my god
so so uh don't worry people in the member stream you'll
you'll see how many how much it was um because like i will
have a stream and i'll be like trigger warning financial bad
poor financial decisions because like i said there was no
budget going in i was just like i you whatever you guys
He's a fucking blank check go wild and then I realized maybe
telling people here's a blank check go wild is not the best
idea Anyway um okay so this this debut has been going has
been planned for like two and a half months i believe um the
reason it wasn't sooner because like i had some i had to
like i guess like figure out some stuff and also like you
know my skin suit wasn't really done done by then um so
there was like a lot of stuff i had to figure out myself
like what i exactly won by two and a half months I sort of
finalized like exactly the idea so I'm gonna show you guys
like uh my initial prompt this is basically like what I
wrote like the very first thing I uh I wrote to people so I
was like so the whole debut is based off so this is my my
pitch basically where uh the what the entire building off on
um so like i said it's like basically my yeah tldr this is
my pitch
there's more by the way if you guys were like tldr there's
more
this is basically the the pitch i gave to the team into like
the animators and everything of um by the way in this pitch
I didn't even include the animation pitch too because I made
a separate pitch for the animator because this it doesn't
include the animation this this is like the gaming area of
of everything so um so like in this This is just a gaming
pitch of the, like, overlay, of the gaming overlay, like,
dokeyverse and everything.
Um, and the animation had its own, very own, uh, very own,
like, pitch itself.
That was even, that was, like, also pretty long.
That was, like, several paragraphs as well.
So, basically, this is how it all started.
Like, I'm not even gonna read this because it is definitely
TLDR, but, uh, I had this idea.
For a year.
I've had this idea.
I wanted to do this for a year.
So this was like a...
Because this was a super duper ambitious project.
And I think the reason why I also didn't do this.
I had it on the back burner.
Because I've had like...
I had like several ideas that I put on back burners.
And then I'll be like, do I have the money for this type
deal?
uh and i i was like i don't really think i have the funding
for this yet so i would just put it i have like several
ideas that that's in my brain that's like been in the back
burner and uh and everything um so now when i finally
decided to do this idea i was like i have enough money to
like be like no budget go wild
because like I felt like this idea this um this idea that I
had um for it was incredibly ambitious and I knew that this
would require a lot a lot a lot of money um so I never
really did it I always kept it I had like I actually had a
um what's the word I had a lower budget like an actual
budget plan to for a lower I guess like a lower tier version
of this like not as not as ambitious but like more budget
friendly um but uh it was never actually implemented um so
I'm happy that now I have the funding to do like the actual
full plan of this project um because like i said it
definitely had uh it had a lot of elements playing into it
it was yeah oh my gosh there's so many by the way this is
not related to behind the scenes But I wanted to show you
guys new emotes, by the way.
New emotes!
I won't be getting these until Doakumi is over because the
artist is at Doakumi at the moment.
So new emotes, guys!
It's gonna, we're gonna have the emotes, like maybe like
next week, I think, when the artist is back from Doakumi and
sends these files to me.
the the fifth one uh the fifth one is is my favorite so far
because we never had the fifth one before but i was like i
want this type of eat i want despair i will yes we're gonna
have map again guys um classic map emo where i'm like where
the are we guys where are we i don't know where i don't
Sorry!
Also, I need to remember to remove the screenshots, guys,
because I'm worried my opiates might crash.
I need to remember to remove the screenshots instead of
dragging it in.
All right, anyway, sorry, I really had to, I really wanted
to show that to you guys because um before before before uh
we go to real behind the scenes so oh my god 30 minutes has
already passed and we haven't really went to behind the
scenes i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i just i just i just want
to talk to you guys chat i just wanted to talk to you guys i
can't help yapping um what else did i want to say okay sorry
there's like something else i really want to talk about get
into the uh the meat of things fuck what was it i'm trying
to i'm trying to remember right now fuck what was it oh
sorry guys i need to check in checking in okay sorry all
right uh so i had to check in with the quads thing um oh my
gosh sorry i need to remember i need to remember what it is
that I wanted to talk about regarding emotes.
What the fuck was it?
I actually did write some notes down.
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Intro will be done soon.
Intro.
New intro.
I'm going to give you guys a sneak peek to the new intro.
Okay, I didn't save it, but don't worry.
I am a bug.
Oh, anime emotes.
I'm so happy because I'm going to be working with the person
who did my old animated emotes.
If you guys remember the classic anime emotes that we had
it's gonna be animated by the same person I was really happy
because um I Found the twitter and it was last known
activity a year ago and I was like Where did he go?
I was just like Where did he go?
So I had like backup I was like researching um backup
animators for emotes and like like five tabs i have five
tabs open up their twitter twitter and stuff and then i
think like two days ago they're like oh yeah oh yeah because
like i like dm them and i had their discord like i remember
their discord username so then i like added them on this
girl's like are you are you alive and they're like they're
like yeah like i could still add i can animate your i would
love to animate your emotes again like but like are you okay
with we can't do it we still have some people we have to
animate for and like i'm not doing it full time anymore but
like are you okay with waiting i'm like yeah i'm okay with
waiting because i really like how they
their animations if you guys remember how the monkey looked
like before like it's honestly one of my favorite animated
emotes so and also oh the cheer too the cheer was really
pretty so i was really happy of that you know they're still
alive on the internet and it might be a while before we can
get animated emotes back again but like i'm just happy that
you know they're still around i'm just I mean, they're
still, they're still around.
I don't know, because it's like, you know, it's like, oh,
man, when you find the person you like working with and you
just, you don't want to work with someone different because
you're so used to working with them.
Boy, they give the super chat, thank you, thank you.
If I make a cardboard cutout of Doki, should I call her a
Doki board?
Honestly, it looks pretty sweet.
But yes, it'll be really cool, though, if you make a Doki
cutout.
Thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you.
But yes, anyway, as I was saying, okay, let me grab the, uh,
let me grab, uh, the, uh, okay, I need to download.
Download time.
All right, I don't know if there's audio.
There's audio.
That'll be awkward.
But yes, here's, here you go.
Here's a sneak peek of the new intro.
Um, they'll be done, I think, like, by the end of the month.
Uh, yeah!
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry if it's loud.
Uh, I think it's this, yeah.
We'll loop it.
Dad is here!
Yeah!
Dad's gonna be here!
But yes, this is a sneak peek of the new intro.
I decided to have both Dad and you guys there with me
because at first they were just, they removed the Dragoon.
And I was like, no!
The Dragoon will be with us!
so whenever that's done we'll be uh whenever the reason why
it took so long was that we were trying to figure out the
background um like there was a lot of like background
possibilities but honestly I did not like any of the newer
backgrounds and um I feel really bad because I made the
animator go through like lots and lots of variations for the
background so like here was some of them by the way this is
not just the only uh the only backgrounds that they sent me
and i honestly i honestly thought out of all of them the
original background color uh with the old skin suit uh
looked the best overall because um because like um i wanted
to make sure like everybody popped out so like i know
somebody was like oh but i looked six like six though but
like dad blends into six way too much so um and also like we
try to play around with three and four and um it was just
not it did not look as appealing as i would have liked um
that's why that's why i went with uh classic because like I
understand like six I and the Dragoon pop up a lot but dad
blended in way too much so I was like uh gotta go so and
seven in the classic one everybody um everybody looked good
I want to make sure everybody is good um that's why that's
why it was like uh that's why it took a while it took they
were they this could have been ready like the day after
debut but then i was like background colors and then we
played around with background colors and then we played
around with background colors for so long and then i was
like i'm sorry i just i just like seven i just like the
original i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry for making you do so
many background colors I'm sorry.
Ritual, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
All for bad financial decisions.
Love new skin suit.
The flesh bang is my favorite.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I think my favorite is just how fluid everything.
I'm just so not used to it.
Like, I'm so not used to, like, how fluid the rigging is,
honestly.
It's actually crazy.
me oh it's so it oh my gosh it's it's it's insane i'm so
used to barely moving
it is it's it's it's it's actually like i can't sometimes i
just can't stop looking at myself because i was like damn
fuck i'm hot
actual sorry now we're at the real I'm so sorry we're at the
real behind the scenes so there was one thing that really
wanted to show you guys I'm gonna say I can find if I where
I saved it okay it's a mess um a lot of this stuff is like
super messy right now because I just just like right click
saved everything so I'm gonna see if I can find this concept
art that I really really wanted to show you guys because uh
this concept art i i don't know if you guys remember it but
uh there was a concept art where uh where i showed you guys
a tomato uh do you guys do you guys remember that uh
guys do you guys remember the tomato from that showed and I
was like I love this this tomato shit is like my favorite
thing so far that tomato was actually concept art for one of
the sketches that it was supposed to be we had a lot of
concept sketches regarding like the splash art and it sucked
because honestly it was like one of the hardest decisions to
make and because the splash screen we had so many splash
screen alternatives it was actually um oh my gosh i'm gonna
try to find it right now i'm trying to find okay here it
this oh yeah this is from claire so okay so okay so i'm
looking at it you guys see a familiar face right here
Okay, anyway, so the tomato actually came from that splash
art.
And that's why I was like, guys, I love this.
I wish there was so many choices.
There was one way to ride a dragon.
It was so good.
It was so difficult.
Guys, this has to be like one of the most difficult choices.
Like I went with three because the reason why, like, okay,
so...
so uh for these concept art um i had to make sure that
everything is the concept art has a lot of varieties going
in and so i wanted to make sure like each concept each
splash art each splash art is a different theme so we had
already had like a splash art dedicated to uh the new look
which was like the fire the the fire in the background and
then we had one that was dedicated to the tomato like the
one where like you were holding the tomato and then we had
one of the we had a shooting one scene and then we had like
another like relaxing scene so I thought so in the end we
picked three because it was like something we didn't have we
didn't have like an alt dokey scene yet and we didn't have
like a concert like you know like maybe like a concert uh
patch the cosmetic And there was an all, yeah, there was one
with all the dragoons and everything.
So it was really difficult because we had so many different,
we had, I needed to make sure there was a lot of variations
of the Splash R.
Because like, oh my gosh, all of these look amazing.
But we already had a lot of concepts with the other four.
And I was like, okay, we didn't have a concert scene yet.
So that's why I picked three.
But oh my god, okay.
where the tomato comes from like the the tomato right yeah
so i wish we went with one just for the tomato i think one
was my favorite when it came to like um just for that face
that was my favorite all right so this is another concept we
had um so this one um this one was Also, another for the
splash art, as you see, we got B2.
A B2 was the one we ended up with in the end.
So it was like B1, B2.
I thought it would be B2.
I picked A2 and B2.
I didn't pick A1.
Like I said, we already had the concept art with, we already
had the splash art with like Alt Girl Doki with the concert.
And then we had A3.
choose a3 because we already had one where like there's a
shooting scene for a3 so that was like either a2 or b2 and
then uh we went with b2 in the end because like i said like
uh we wanted like a little teaser for like when the patch
goes live and then the teaser in the background and stuff
like that there were so i told you guys there were so many
concepts that we ended up not doing because like uh all the
artists they would draw like uh a bunch of concepts all
together and then we had to pick one because there was just
enough time for like one or two if we're lucky one or two um
for the splash art and it's one of the hardest decisions to
make honestly i think this was like the splash art was like
the hardest decisions to make because i had to make sure
everything was like balanced well and like there's there's
like enough like there's enough variations to stuff all
right here's another one that'll show you guys like i think
we had like so many artists in splash art so i have so many
to show so here's another here's some other concepts that we
have um oh my gosh one was so good so we had all of these
they were all really really like i said they It was so
difficult to pick.
We went with five in the end because we didn't have anything
related with the tomato yet.
So we went with five because we were like, okay, we should
get something related to tomato because it makes sense.
And then I didn't want to do six because I was like, okay,
so the anime trailer, the anime trailer had already had like
something to do with cowboy tomato.
So, and then, and obviously a lot of, them were pretty funny
but what is something more peaceful because we had a lot of
funny we had some funny ones going in so I was like okay
we're gonna go with five because it's like a peaceful like
it's different it's peaceful um and and everything I didn't
want to do anything that really revealed what I what I was
gonna look like so that's why we scrapped despite seven and
eight looking really fucking cool it's gonna spoil like
parts of the outfit or like parts of the skin suit so we
didn't do seven or a it was i think i chose like one six
yeah i remember it was like one six or five and then we
settled with five but yes the decisions i had to make was
very very difficult um let's see start heaven thank you for
the super chat thing thank you real talk could we like
crowdfund a full version of a2 or something think of a super
chat thank you thank you maybe in the future i won't mind
like making a community post on maybe like members or uh
maybe like members because it's gonna be a members wallpaper
um i mean well if you guys want these as wallpapers because
wallpapers are gonna be like member like uh the ones that in
this in this they're not members they're all gonna be free
the the splash art the ones that got made into actual splash
art um will be uh will be available for But if you do guys
want some of these concept arts turned into actual
wallpapers, I might ask in the members, like, and, like,
post all these concepts and ask you guys which one you guys
want to, like, make into, like, members' wallpapers in the
future.
Because that's actually a good idea.
Because that's actually a really good idea.
But, yes, this is another one.
Let me see.
I could, there was, like, a couple or so many.
Guys, you're...
I had to make a lot of decisions.
um let's see um all right there's this one and then did i
show this one no i didn't show this one yet and then i gotta
make sure i close my tabs because while i was saving i just
need you guys to know while i was saving behind the scenes
images uh i blue screen because i didn't close any of my
tabs i'm so so i need to remind myself to close tabs so I do
not blue screen because that would be very awkward um I'm
trying to remember okay I know all right I know I there was
a lot of concepts from this artist because we did not pick
the other concept we did not pick some of the other ones
that they first sent so I'm trying to make Find the right
one I'm trying to make sure oh there oh there was there were
these okay um all right all right so I need you guys to know
the the first name that we were gonna that we Came up with
was oh this one okay as you guys can see um oh there were so
many good cons this was like one of the first cons of ours
we received oh but there were so many
We had a lot of really, really good ideas here.
So I think you guys can see that we went with one because we
wanted an action scene.
You see two.
Two was the inspiration behind.
I really, I loved.
I loved two a lot.
Two was actually also one of my favorites.
That was given to Nico to do in the end because we had so
many concepts that were really, really, really good.
Another artist took two to draw for their own splash art.
And that's where the, you know, the bar scene was inspired
by.
Because I thought it was like, oh my god, that's actually so
clever.
That was really, really clever.
So that's so huge shout out to X Trident for coming with all
these concepts.
Because that's where I got my inspiration for the background
itself as well.
But yes, the original game title was going to be Flock Chat.
that came that was came up by the the team I was like no I
just thought it didn't roll off the tongue well like you
know flock champs it just it felt awkward like saying it so
then that's why I stole your ideas dragons so I really
appreciate you guys uh I I stole dokeyverse and battle birds
from you guys in the memberships because i was like hey guys
um i'm gonna i need an idea for a game title because like um
i'm gonna be making a wallpaper themed around um i mean
technically i wasn't wrong there are wallpapers so um so i
was like hey guys i need some game ideas and then i think
like there was one someone said dokeyverse and then another
one was flock champs and not flock times was like one we
rejected and everyone said battle birds and battle birds was
like the most upvoted up dudes going in so i was like all
right we're gonna i'm gonna steal that and then be like hey
guys i came up with no okay i didn't say that to the other
it's like yeah so i asked the members i think we're gonna go
with these i these names uh
Anyway, so these are the concept art.
Oh, four looked really good.
Four looked like in Apex Legends, like, opening.
Because, like, originally for the devs, it was going to be
just, like, normal Doki Bird productions.
But then we saw Doki Verse, and then we're like, oh, Doki
Verse will work so well.
It's going to work so well as, like, a, like, a, you know, a
game publishing company, a publisher name.
So then that's why we stole, we borrowed.
It was, you guys posted on my channel, so it's my ID.
You know, that's like, you know, like that's TOS shit.
Like, if you post it on our website, it's ours now.
Because you willingly posted on the website.
You know, you know that rule that some companies have to
like legally, they're like, it's not yours.
It's ours now.
It's like how, oh, like.
Yeah, I think I remember that's why like Deven art low-key
died because even I released a new TOS being like if you
post this on our website on Deven art it's now legally we
can use it for anything we want because you posted it on our
our Website so like technically if you pull
Because you you commented willingly on my mean any of those
it's mine now how to kill you website no i'm joking guys i'm
joking it's our idea okay it's our idea it's not my it's
ours um um but yes here were all the concepts uh for from x
trident like it's so difficult there were so many uh really
really good ideas that it was very difficult to be like
which one is the because they could only do like every
almost i think almost all the artists i think every artist
yeah every artist could only do one and because they can
only do one it was a very difficult decision uh that to yeah
pick one they are all so good they're all so good i had to
make one decision
um let's see um so many thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you finally got my two donkey keychains hung one
on the mirror of my car i was surprised by the amount of
import taxes though was 20 euros goddamn taxes where are
they fun where are they making anyway if if i can still
fucking live on mars what's the point of paying taxes don't
please don't audit me I pay my taxes, please don't It was a
joke Canadian government, please don't audit me, I do pay my
taxes Thank you for the super chat, thank you Thank you Um,
Cass, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you So
you're saying that we reply with stuffy things They will
become, no, I can pick and choose Uh, I can pick and choose
like what What is ours?
Thank you for the super chat, Cass Thank you, thank you For
legal reasons, that was a joke Canadian government.
And if the American government is watching, I'm happy I'm
not in America or part of a country that's part of the
European Union.
Is that too much of a low blow?
You'll understand if you're part of the European Union.
let's see you know Canadian taxes fucking sucks as well
Canadian fucking poster serve it's okay you know what's
fucked up so it's like I live in a country that's part of
the European meaning sad face okay you know what fucking
sucks Canadian Canadian business owners will understand it
is more expensive to ship within Canada than it is to ship
out to America like what kind of but we live in the same
country what bullshit is that it is it's actually yes if
you're if you're shipping parcels in Canada letters don't
count by the way and we're not talking about letters but
like If you're using, like, if you're shipping, like,
parcels and stuff, it's more expensive to ship within the
country.
It's bullshit.
Like, why?
Like, what do you mean?
I don't, I don't understand.
I actually don't understand the Canadian, like, support post
offices.
But please make it make sense.
Like, oh my god, I don't understand, like, Canada, please.
How, how, why do we do this?
Okay, um, Andy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's not like we're fucking traveling mountains all the
time.
It's not like we're, like, fucking, it's not like, we don't
have cars like oh my god the user post office guys dokey
merch is helping got all dokey merch is funding the Canadian
healthcare system right now if you are a Canadian dragoon
and you're like why the fuck is it so expensive to ship
within Canada I I I want you to know that I'm helping
funding, I'm helping to fund, we're, we're funding the
healthcare system together.
You're buying stuff from my store.
I have to pay, you're paying the shipping and I have to pay
the taxes too.
We're funding the Canadian healthcare system together.
Oh my god.
It's actually crazy.
I don't understand.
Every time I like see the shipping of shipping to America
versus shipping in Canada.
And then the thing is America.
But I don't understand.
How come when you United States dragoons, when you're
shipping in the United States, it's cheaper.
But when you're shipping to Canada, they add $20.
Like, a small fucking item you buy in America as a Canadian
dragoon.
And you guys, it's like, and you compare it to, like, you
ship in the States, versus shipping to Canada, it's, like,
$20 extra.
But we live next door.
We live next door.
And it's cheaper for us to ship to you.
So should it be the same?
I'm sorry, I'm just really mad.
Like, that shit pisses me.
I just, because like, if it's going to be expensive in
Canada, why can't it be expensive in America?
Considering a trade-off for the healthcare.
No name, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't understand.
I'll never understand.
Lord Kurosus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's the freedom tax every American knows about it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I got somebody who was like, it's often cheaper to ship to
the U.S.
and drive down to get it.
Yeah, you fucking ship it to the like, ship it to the
closest city in America.
That's closest to you.
And then you drive down to the border to pick it up.
You don't want to pay $20 in Canadian shipping I'm sorry I
got I got sidetracked there I got really really passionate
about this topic because I Guys I know like being Canadian
maybe it looks great but it's There's there's the little
things that just make it not so great
It's just, I just feel like it's, it's a highway robbery
because the Canadian dollar sucks compared to the American
dollar, but yet you guys get cheaper shipping.
Like, what, what's the point?
Our Canadian dollar sucks shit compared to the American
dollar.
But yet somehow we have to pay more?
to ship within our own country make it make sense alright
I'm done I'm sorry I'm really I'm I'm really passionate
about this topic because it because when I first found out
about it when we were like dealing with the store and then I
was like looking at the shipping prices because we were
fixing the shipping stuff and
I was like adding my staff team was like why is it like this
and then they're like it's supposed to be like this I was
like that doesn't make because like at first okay the thing
is like at first we had like an American staff member that
was handling the store stuff and then they were even they
were like i don't understand our our american staff member
that was handling the story at first was like i don't
understand why is the canadian shipping more expensive than
the american shipping and then i was like that's what i was
thinking and then and because like we were printing out the
labels and stuff and i were we had like a scale of it we had
all the products so we're starting to print out the labels
and then we're like wait we fucked up the shipping prices
because Apparently, we price Canadian shipping lower than
American shipping at first.
But everything is fixed now, by the way.
All the shipping prices.
And then so then we had, later on, we had a Canadian.
Our distributor is from Canada.
And they took over the shop.
So the distributor was going through it and was like, no,
that's how it works.
Like in Canada, it's just more expensive to ship within your
own country.
And I was like, why?
And then the American staffman was like, that doesn't make
sense.
And then, and then, And then our Canadian industry was like,
no, no, it's just like that.
I mean, you can stop.
I was like, but that doesn't make sense.
I was like, that's what I was saying.
It doesn't make sense.
And industry was like, no, it's just like that.
Like, that's how it is.
Like, oh my God.
Okay, sorry.
Back to the concept.
I'm sorry, I went like 20 minutes on this.
This is something I'm very passionate about.
It's just, it's just something I'm incredibly passionate
about.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to the team.
Anyway, here are some more concept art.
This artist actually did the, um, uh, I think it was the,
one with the fire behind, but they sent us extra concept
art.
I decided not to do this because it overlapped with, uh, it
overlapped with like Trident's initial idea regarding the,
um, the shooting guns thing.
So that's why, uh, we decided not to go with any of these
concept art, um, because, uh, it overlapped already with
Trident's pitch.
Um, so we went with the one with the dragoons and the...
the fire in the back oh my god it's so weird to just jump
back into talking about this
after being like incredibly passionate all right billboard
concept all right billboard concept all right this one was
fun because the billboard stuff was decided sort of like at
the last minute type deal not like last last minute but like
after when we were building up the 3d set we realized we
wanted to add billboards so this was like the original
please don't demonetize me youtube but this was like one of
the original um one of the original um we have more concept
art for splash art but like i didn't i have to scroll to
find it by the way so i'm just going by with like what i
have so far um this was like the one of the original
concepts so we're like we want to do something as a parody
of gamer subs so like we had dad subs and then later on here
are the oh my god this is a big file we had like the other
uh okay okay i love the we almost went with 2b by the way we
almost uh we almost went with 2b because i thought 2b and 2c
was really good um but these were some of the concepts uh
regarding uh regarding the um billboards and stuff so we had
like stuff with uh at first it wasn't gonna be dad subs it
was gonna be some fucking energy drink uh we almost went
with 2b and 2c and then we're like wait we should do a
parody of gamer subs it's gonna make more sense you know
with gamer subs instead um so here are some of our billboard
concepts i think this was also billboard yes this was okay
okay some of them are I forgot about what some of them
looked like, so looking at it again is pretty funny.
Alright, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
At least this tip is more for you than it costs for me.
Also, desktop, YouTube, not liking PayPal for some fucking
reason.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, Rx.
Sorry, I was slurping my slushy.
My mango slushy.
But yes, this was more concept art.
regarding dad subs and then some of the uh billboard designs
for it and then we had we had they had they they made
concept art of the flavors uh the branding of dad subs oh
guys look so fucking stupid
um um gary thank you for the super chat thing thank you got
this country shipping cost sucks anyway here's the next
concept all right thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you um what else do i have what else uh i'm trying to
find the other oh yes here are some oh yeah here you go
here's like the billboard by the way uh we're guys are
wondering when is the vr chat gonna be out um in public um
the we are currently post not postponing but i I'm letting
the 3D team have a little break at the moment.
I'm letting my entire team have a little break before we go
back into work mode because it was two and a half months of
work almost every day for everybody.
Like they had meetings.
They actually had like staff meetings and stuff to like
talk, discuss, and build off of everything and like set
design and design the entire concept.
So like I'm good.
Because like I actually had one of the team members being
like, so when were we doing the VR chat world?
When are we going to join the server?
And I was like, oh, I'm making the server now, but
everybody's going to have a little break at the moment
before we go back into actually doing stuff for this.
Because there's obviously, like, I want to add more to just
the world.
I want to have, like, little fun games in there, if
possible.
And maybe flesh out the place a little bit more.
Like, build off, like, how did we get here?
Like, could we do something where we, um, when we spawn in,
there's a little area to spawn in, like, a respawn point.
You know, like, in Team Fortress 2, there's, like, a,
respawn locker or like in overwatch there's like a place for
you to respawn at so i want to like add more lord and lord
building to this i know like in the game you drop down and
stuff but like obviously in vr chat you can't do that or
maybe like actually another idea i have it's just you spawn
in like a room and you have to click something there and
then you drop down i wonder you can do that that would be
cool like um you you spot in like in lobby-esque area and
then like you you click a button and then you like you click
a cue or something and then you like you drop down into the
world that would be i think that would be really fun to do
like there's like character selection in the respot like the
spot like the selection room and stuff it's like i don't
know if you guys ever know this classic vr chat world um
that was based off of sword art online i being like
incredibly stupid because um um it was like oh a vr chat
world that is like um that is basically a replica sword art
online and then you drop into this room it's like somebody's
room and then i remember i was so stupid because i was like
what the fuck where's the sword art online room like the
background looks like a forest and there's castle and
everything and then apparently you were supposed to click on
a pc in that world and then you get into the sword art
online world but i didn't know that i was so confused i was
just like um i was like what do you mean like why is it just
this person's room this random guy's room where is the world
by the way i've never watched sword art online so like all i
know about it are the memes i just thought it was cool i
wanted to look at it anyway i figured that out like two
years later when another friend of mine was like yo let's go
to that sword art online world they updated it i was like
what wait that world wait there's more to it than the room
there's there's more to it than the fucking room
um anyway uh so i was like i think that would be a really
cool idea to be able to like You spawn into something
outside of that, but then you can click a button to be
dropped down into the gaming world of the area.
So, yeah, like I said, it's not going to be something that's
going to be done right away.
Like, even though we have majority of this stuff, like,
technically finished, we still, there's a lot of, like,
stuff I want to do to, like, just build off of the world.
All right, so here are some concept arts, by the way.
Like I said, we had to figure out a lot.
I don't remember what this is.
I think it was just set dressing.
Like, we had so many cons.
Like, some of the things, I'm like, wait, what is this?
But, oh, I remember this.
So, we had, like, loot boxes, too.
Like, what the, how the loot box is going to, like, the loot
box system was going to work and stuff.
So, there's a, um, one was the loot box.
And then one is, uh, one is, like, uh, crate loot crates in
the game itself.
So, like, you know, when you're opening.
the loot box like these were the concept art uh so it's like
a carton and stuff uh but yeah we went with the blue because
obviously that looks the best so some of the concept art for
this oh my god there were some 3d models that we weren't
able to use so this is one this was uh nice wigs uh dragoon
so there were so many there was i don't know we used this
one because there were so many we had some deleted scenes
and stuff so and we couldn't add everything but this was I
love the mustache the mustache was so good
um and then we have um here's here's Axis uh Dragoon
Dragoonify Dragoons your Oshi no oh
my Oshi my Oshi's a
um oh yeah i showed um tempo apparently was asking me for
the files because he wants to make into a plushie like uh
for himself like he wants he was like oh my god so cool can
i have the file so i can make it in a blush like no problem
man bro fucking do whatever the fuck you want these are
because like i'm not using it for anything else other than
like just for the sake of reveal so it's like it was just
gonna rot like like it was like nothing that was gonna be
like done with these models other than the fact because i'm
not gonna you know it's it's their identity it's their
property like this their likeness so like i just made it for
the sake of you know this the debut reveal like the debut
reveal so i was like if you guys like i know like philian
actually reached out to me and asked for like the sticker
because she wanted to like her own discord email because I
wasn't gonna sell the sticker it was just made for the sake
of the reveal like all the stuff that was based off of uh
like my friends and people I've collabed with and everything
um it was just for the sake of the reveal and like like oh
my god I recognized them like in Easter eggs and stuff um so
that's why I was just like yay yeah if you guys want to do
anything with it like feel free to because I was not gonna
do anything with it I'm not gonna make your likeness um but
if you guys want it like just ask me and i'll hand it over
to you guys uh but yes stuff like that uh what else oh um
here's some concept art of uh the logos and stuff so um so
this is what it could have as you see i settled with oh my
god making decisions on the look of and aesthetic of things
so difficult honestly it's actually such a difficult
decision um Yeah, so here's some concept art of the logo and
stuff and then I think I asked for like parody logos Because
I don't remember I don't remember I think like me and
someone else in the team were asking for like Oh, yeah, we
should have like parody logos and stuff.
So there's like some We were like basing off like some like
making parodies off of other games and stuff to make it look
real to make Doki verse like a real battle net slash steam
like I was like I needed to I need the lore I need the lore
building everything must feel like it could possibly be an
actual game client where games on yes there's someone's like
oh what about duck by daylight I do have that right here
there was like other oh my god I need to find it but there's
like concept art for like like scrapped game logos let's see
where is it I see okay there a horror game.
Oh, there's, yeah, there's, there's basically a dead by
daylight, dead by daylight, dead by daylight, was it parody?
And then we had, oh my gosh, we had so, there's so many,
there's so many, and then, oh, so here's a full res of the
poster, by the way.
this poster that was there we had so many little art stuff
that was there that's like if you blink you'll miss it so
this poster was on the animation that was the animation at
the beginning with the little dragoon like in the backboard
there's like little stuff in the backboard and everything so
it was like little small art stuff like little small moments
in easter days that were like if you blink you would not see
this so we had this poster made oh my this other thing i
specifically requested it um this other thing let me see i
can find where i saved where did i save it i did not save
any of this this one i specifically this was right after
right after the rust stream i was like i need a book
dedicated to the blood god
Right after the rest stream, I was like, at the team.
I need somebody, because they're like, what kind of Easter
eggs do you want?
And I was like, add a book about the blood guy.
So, there's like something that we added in, like,
retroactively, because we were like, what kind of reference
do we need?
Also, here's Iggun with Gun.
uh here's here's a guano with guns also we had oh my gosh i
wish you guys could have seen the details of the death box
uh this is the death box i love the little details i wish i
think like you guys will be able to see it in the vr chat
world if guys whenever it's out but there's like so many
little details with the 3d modeling and everything it's like
you know oh my gosh the little like little ghost goon there
uh little wisp goon right there and then we had like um gun
concepts too um of everything because we didn't want to like
replicate exactly the wingman but like we had you know um
it's like a parody a a parody of the gun and stuff like that
and then like We built all the models, by the way, all the
models in Dadwood Canyon made from scratch.
Nothing was we didn't buy anything from the Unity store.
We didn't like, you know, take any of the models that were
already pre-made.
All of these models were 100% made from scratch.
So we own the models and everything.
And so like because you know it's ours we didn't buy
anything from the unity store we it was literally made from
scratch i think this one okay what i'm gonna show you it has
to be one of my favorite models because it's so cute look at
these cactuses
i'm sorry but look at these cactuses they're so cute like
it's one of my favorite I don't know.
It's just... Look, it's just so cute.
I don't know.
I just get out of it.
I need you guys to see the cactuses.
They're so fucking cute.
I get out of it.
Sorry.
It's just so adorable.
Also, some concepts, some 3D model concepts of, like, our
version of the Nessie.
the uh the legally distinct uh nessie plushie uh with long
goon so they're like the long goon model uh plushie and then
we'll have like it rendered i don't know if i saved the
rendered version no wait i did so then i'm looking like this
and then it came into uh so a goonie yeah
where stuff do i have um oh yeah here's like a map too i'll
give you guys like 3d shots of the map because it's actually
it's actually crazy like that all of this was made from
scratch like oh my god like seeing it all together like all
of this being made like an entire actual world being made
and scratched by our uh 3d team like holy shit like look it
looks like an actual map like um because it happens so fast
so you don't like take in the fact that a lot of this
there's like stuff on the in the water and everything and in
2.5 months too like in 2.5 months so there's so many things
everywhere that was just like uh this is like the zoom out.
When you zoom out, you realize, okay, that's not a lot.
But when you zoom in, you're like, whoa, holy shit.
That is a lot of stuff going on.
Oh, and then one of my staff members was like, where are
they dropping?
Staff member, one of the teams, sorry, not staff member, one
of the debut team, project team made this and was like, all
right, guys, where are they left?
What POI are they like, I thought it was so funny Where is
TSN gonna land I thought it was so fucking clever I was so
silly If Battle Birds was an eSport What is their POI?
Whatever Oh yeah here And then we had Did I show this one?
already oh yeah i didn't show this one but here's a better
picture of dad says okay i'm gonna use the bathroom real
quick uh i'll be right back you guys can talk amongst
yourselves for a little bit give me a sec i'll be right back
all right i'm back back from the bathroom break okay let me
see let me go in order now of oh wait let's see what team am
i on all right quads shack first set of teams for king's cat
as okay what team am i on all right guys where am i i am
with poor what sorry okay it's okay they won't be watching
this so they won't know i hood them
okay so each game is going each game is going to be
randomized each game is going to be randomized so we're
gonna be with different people each time anyway so
Okay, I recognize, okay, so I recognize the first one.
The first one is dropped.
I recognize him.
I did not who dropped.
I who'd the two other players, because I don't know.
I'm not familiar with them.
Oh, my God, they did put me as the lowest rank.
Yes!
It's like P1, P2, P3, and P4.
It's marked by like, how good these people are.
How good these people are at 8.
and I wrote in the sign-up form, I was like, I am, like,
they were like, what's the highest rank you got?
And I was like, diamond.
I was like, I'm in.
Because I was like, I'm so, so, so they put me at P4, which
is like, like the people who are the lowest ranked.
Guys, look, all the other, guys, All the other D, the P4s,
they play this game regularly, okay?
They play this game.
Anyway.
Anyway, so it's not lying.
It's omitting information.
I'm currently, last two seasons ago, I was diamond.
Two seasons ago, I was diamond.
It's omitting information.
Anyway, it's like dropped, Melanie, par, rift.
Wait, don't leave a void.
Yes, I know.
I, even I'm like, whoo, whoo, I'm sorry.
It's okay.
They won't watch this mod because it's like, they think it's
behind the scenes.
I know dropped.
Drops on my team.
This is game one.
And then me.
And then there's me after that.
Team 15 has three players.
Like, how are they gonna play?
Like, the other, okay, you can't say, like, you're, like,
smurfing because like isn't deridium deridium's literally
like pred like what i recognize one person in p4 and that
guy's pred isn't he he lied even more he lied even more he's
a recent pred
um raspberry thank you welcome to the tomato farm welcome
welcome um i remember i recognized the radio i recognized
the radio being like an actual good player i don't recognize
anybody else but i recognized the radio
um anyway But, anyway, thank God they put me at P4.
Yeah.
P1 is where all the good players are.
Like, the actual, like, professional players.
And then, like, and then it goes down from there.
Okay, sorry.
We gotta go back to the...
I had to figure out, like, who...
How many games is this?
How many did I accidentally sign up for?
Six games?
Oh, my...
Ha!
Oh my god, it's six keys Six Okay, we can do this, guys We
can do this Okay, okay Guys, I figured out I don't read
Guys, oh my god I don't read, guys Okay, um Wait, is it
like, okay, first set of teams for, oh, so, like, post the
next troop during, oh, so, like, we're going to be with this
team for two games.
Okay, sorry, every map is a new team.
JK, it's not every game is a new team.
Every map is a new team.
Um, all right, anyway, let's, let's go through.
Sorry, let me actually, let me go through it for a while.
I keep getting distracted.
Oh, my God.
When I have a time limit, it's so bad.
I don't I don't do well with time limits I feel like I waste
more time when I have a time limit this has to be the
slowest behind the scenes feature I've ever done because
because I keep getting distracted by things all right anyway
so here was like a concept of a concept of flock champs um
we were like thinking of making more parodies off of apex in
general but the thing is i said i wanted like overwatch and
apex um so that's why we scrapped this uh because i wanted
to be more so focused on the fact that i don't want to make
it just in apex priority parody i want it to be like apex
and overwatch because you know they're both games that um
are very dear to my heart And like, basically, like, I
started off, like, my curious sort of started off because of
Overwatch.
And that's why I wanted to make it more so, like, a
accumulation of two, not, like, just one game.
Anyway, here's, like, a concept of what the starting screen
was going to look like as well.
So you can see, like, we're figuring out the GUIs and
everything.
And this was what the original idea of the character
selection, obviously, we went in different directions.
with the character selection, like, a lot better.
You know, when you load into the game, the character
selection looked a lot different from before.
So this was what it was originally going to look like.
And then we also have, by the way, it's more so, like, blink
and you'll see it.
But, like, remember when, like, we saw Dead Tomato in the
animation?
That was actually its own model.
So the tomato model, the tomato model, the 3D model was
actually its own thing.
You saw a dead tomato on the floor, that was a tomato 3D
model.
So the tomato has its own 3D model.
So it's, yeah.
so it's not like you know uh it was you know it was actually
its own thing um yeah it was i'm glad we had it like i
didn't know i we didn't know what to really do with it until
later on because we were like anyway here's the i just like
i want a tomato model we don't know what to do with it but
we're just like we want it you know we we want it also
originally I scrapped this idea because I, I, um, it was
good on, uh, like, it was a good idea, but I scrapped it
because I thought that, um, I, I, we were, it was originally
the character select, uh, was going to include other
dragoons of my friends.
so you can like select we could select my friends as a
playable character but i scrapped the idea because i was
like i want them to be skins i don't want them i want the
dragoons themselves to be the playable character but i want
so like these are icons for like character select but i was
like i want the dragoons to be the playable characters and
then my friends to be the skins because i thought it would
make more sense like
because I don't know I just I just feel like to be more
immersive it would make more sense to uh to make the dragons
themselves be the model like the actual like characters you
can pick and then you can change the model skins uh with
these guys uh so we scrapped that idea and that's why we
don't we didn't use it all right I'm slowly going through
like I'm slowly oh my gosh here's some background shots by
the way like not full background shots but like Like, here's
some...
I need to remove delete my tabs.
I'm so scared.
I'm going to get a blue screen.
I'm...
I need to remind myself.
Don't delete your tabs.
Or you're going to get a blue screen.
Here, I love background work.
But here are some, like, background work of the Tomato
Reveal trailer.
And let's see.
I'm trying to, like, think, see if there's, like, stuff.
So...
Oh, my God.
There's four.
45 pages What were we doing?
We were doing so much.
Oh my god, my team worked so hard.
It is 45 There's 45 pages of just files Just of just like
files that were put into this.
This was a lot.
Oh, yeah, this is the initial the initial we were starting
We were starting a 3d modeling here this is where we are
starting the 3d modeling putting stuff in place and
everything um guys give me a sec I'm scrolling right now
give me a sec I'm scrolling through everything at the moment
it's not a very like what's the word it's not a very like
seamless showcase there's just so many things um oh yeah
here's some concept oh yeah so i love i i is like i wish we
did go with i for the fact that the irc i wish we did go
with irc for the fact of the fucking giant floating dragoon
baby but these were uh map concepts that we had for how the
map was gonna look like uh so i think we had it was like the
set dressing of everything i think we went with we went with
d in the end i think d was the one that looks most familiar
to me um but uh i mean an art book i mean are people
actually interested in an art book of this because an art
book is a lot a lot of like fun money to actually um i mean
you guys are to the project team to potentially make an art
book of this if they're interested um because i'm definitely
will not be able to go through everything uh what about
digital pdf i mean a digital i feel like people would
definitely enjoy an art book more than a digital pdf because
it's a i could do both actually i could do both in art book
for like like a collector's edition um and just make it
limited um because art book is a lot of money there's that's
a reason why a lot of art books are like kickstarter
projects uh because it is a lot to like get a publish not
publisher but to get a manufacturer to make like art books
and stuff but i'm i'm down to do it if the project team is
open to it as well um anyway here are some concepts as well
of like stuff like the map would look like and uh what we
had for the map and everything oh my gosh oh my god i did
not realize how how many files we had
oh yeah okay look okay this was funny piece of originally
the um the uh dragons looked way too complicated the initial
like preliminary sketch of of the dragons so like here was
like this is what axle originally looked like and then we
simplified it because it would be a bitch to 3d model and we
felt like it just it's just too much so in the end it went
it turned into this so this is what it turned out into in
the end so originally it was like yeah super complicated and
we felt like it didn't really represent some of the my
friends really well uh so that's why we a lot of the designs
when it came to it um at one point like oh wait let me see
it was like uh okay this is this is this is altars and one
of the altars initially concept which was like like
kaleidoscope
the the kaleidoscope in This was like the initial, um, the
initial concept of, uh, Altair.
Like I said, like, everybody went through.
If we do make an art book, I don't think I'm going to, I'm
not going to include, like, I guess, like, I'm definitely
not going to include, I might include, like, these sketches,
like, the left side, but not, like, you know, screenshots of
fucking company old images.
Anyway, here's the concept, uh, model of, well, like, not
concept model, but, like, it being finished of the, uh, of
the egg itself, the loot box itself.
Oh, and also here, since we had egg with gun, here are
dragoons with guns.
The sequel to egg with gun, we have dragoons with gun.
Let's see, I'm trying to look through some more stuff i'm
scrolling i'm scrolling guys uh oh yeah and here's some
concept art of the sprays itself so we went through
obviously we made parodies of um apex sprays and here's like
some of them so the okay and i had to pick between the
dragon or tomato and i thought the obviously i mean Not
that.
That's not an apex parody.
That's like fucking Saitama.
Saitama parody.
One Punch Man parody.
But, uh, I had to pick between the Dragoon or the Tomato.
And clearly, I went with a better choice.
Not gonna lie.
Let's see.
All right.
I'm at page 11, guys.
Give it up for page 11.
Woo!
I can't get up.
I can't get up on page 11.
I'm like, what the fuck?
45 pages Oh my god this could be like Oh my god if I didn't
have another stream The stream would have gone on for a very
long time Page of the You're almost there We're almost there
Oh yeah here are like Sticker concepts too Like other Um
Other Sticker concepts that we had Uh so We had other Other
stickers of everybody else as well as like different types
of ideas that we were drafting up um and everything so these
were like some of the sketches and ideas that uh some the
artist the artist that was in charge of stickers and sprays
that were um um that gave us and stuff sorry i'm not very
good with words right now also i don't know if you guys know
this but if you look closely at the 3d animation um of the
3d animation you would notice that the guns have stickers on
them so these are like concept stickers they're not the i
don't think these were everything but we actually put like
we tried you know when we made it make it incredibly
immersive um by the way the full on credits is in my
description so um i posted like a credit list of every like
uh they made a credits uh sheet of everybody and click on my
description you'll you'll see like credit like a link to
everybody hmm so it's more so like if you blink you miss a
type deal but the guns do actually have like stickers on
them um to like you know make it more immersive as of like
you know the cosmetics of everything uh so that it has like
cosmetics and stuff um all right i'm scrolling guys i'm on
page 12 now page 12 give it up for page 12 we're we're
getting there
we're making it guys oh my god sorry i'm still scrolling
through because i want to look at things that i do want to
actually show there's a lot of like stuff in there that is
like oh we don't have to show that we don't oh here we go
here's another concept we had so this one we only were shown
two sketches um right here uh obviously you can tell which
one i ended up with because i felt like you know a was such
a cool action pose and everything and i felt like you know i
wanted something more like badass so that's why i went with
a instead of b because you know it looks fucking badass like
like what more do i have this remember to close your tabs,
Doki.
You don't want another blue screen room to close your tabs!
It's just something I tell myself, Doki, you have to close
tabs.
You can't keep everything open.
um, but yeah, that is why we, uh, went with A in general.
Because, like I said, we wanted something that looked like,
uh, that we wanted something that looked like, you know, uh,
something that would look good on on um on like uh on the
splash screen and we want something more dynamic and more
actiony also here is the initial one of the initial concepts
for the my fake battle net legally distinct battle net
if i was a game publishing company um this is what my This
is what my client will look like.
So, like I said, I said I wanted something like Steam or
like BattleNet.
So, yeah, Battlebird.
Battlebird.net.
So, you'd see that at first it was just like names, but I
requested.
I was like, okay, I want like actual fake games.
I think this was the point where I was like, I want to
include fake games because I don't want Battlebirds to be
like the only game on my fake game client.
And I said like to make it more immersive the friends were
adding They have to have usernames like I wanted to make it
because like we don't put our actual names I say as I put
Doki bird as my steam name But like you know what I mean
like if we're like you know if we're not just like content
creators Like we would have like we wouldn't put our act
like our like you know streamer name as our like on our
friends list We would have like some fucking dumbass name
like So that's why I was like we have to change the We have
to change some of the names, some of the names on some of
the friends list because I want to be like, you know, it's
the goon.
So because it's the goon, I wanted to, I wanted to make sure
that like, you know, feels more.
I keep saying immersive, but like that's literally my notes
to them.
Every time they're like, what do you think?
I was like change this because I want to be immersive like I
want to make it feel like you're it could be real like this
is something that you can actually see in the future but not
really because I don't I'm not fucking like Gabe like I'm
not Gabe I don't think I can make this a reality but like in
an alternate universe this could be real so that's like a
lot of my notes even like when we're doing sound design
originally there was no um there was for sound design what
the very first video i was sent of everything put together
there was no game sound like game menu sound so like you
know when you're clicking on the game there was like click
like beep beep pop like you know when you're clicking stuff
like even like buying something on the game menu or like you
know scrolling through and like queuing up that was not
there I was like, this is not an immersive.
We need to have, like, sounds of you clicking stuff.
Of you, like, when you queue up, it goes click.
When you queue, get into a game.
And then when you look at the character select and going
through the characters, there's always a sound there when
you pass by to another character.
So, like, I was very detailed with, like, very stickler with
the attention to detail because it's the details that makes
it.
Like the sound design.
It's literally...
Yeah, the menu sound effects and everything.
That wasn't there.
The menu sound effects weren't there.
So, like, I specifically was, like, super anal about that
thing, those things.
Because, like, without it, it just seemed like a regular
video.
So, like, the sound design with things like that pushes a
regular video to something that was, like, wait, is this
real?
Like, so it makes you be like...
oh my god wait wait is this like it makes you doubt yourself
and it makes you doubt yourself being like wait is this real
which what i saw in chat it really did like people were like
doubting themselves and me like oh my god wait a minute like
am i looking at a am i looking at like is this gonna be
released to all of us like um uh anyway here's another one
okay i'm gonna showed this because you might notice
something is very different.
This was the original concept for the splash art.
You can see that we changed some of the characters there.
The reason why I changed some of the characters there was
because I thought that a lot of some of these people were
around, were already had their own Easter egg.
So I said like, okay, we're going to have to remove this.
We have to remove that.
I removed some people in there only because they already
their own appearances in a different area and because of
that uh we swapped out some of the dragons there because we
want to be fair to um because I know there's like other
dragons that didn't show up that was in like the stickers
and stuff like that um but we try to make it because I was
like okay these guys showed up a lot they already had an
appearance in that area so I want to swap this with somebody
else because um they didn't have as much screen time as the
others so that's why like yeah this was the original and
that's like remove me because i felt like i just wanted this
to be like a dragon splash art so um so i was like remove me
i don't want to i don't want to be in the saloon right now
remove me now all right now i'm scrolling i'm scrolling
again guys oh okay these these i really want to show you
guys because like um let's see i know like uh i'm trying to
remember which one okay oh it's the egg okay so i'm gonna
show you guys a video um because uh like during the
character character select screen there were some videos
that were not shown because it got cut for time so this was
one of them which i thought was really cute i
like you guys didn't see this but he flipped over which i
wanted you guys to see i just want you guys to see him flip
over you guys weren't able to see that because it got cut it
got like cut in half this is the character select screen so
that we had i think the others didn't get cut in half as
badly as the egg so i'm just gonna have that play for a
little bit in the background while i look
Um, oh my gosh, I want to show you guys the concepts for,
um, for some of the game icons, because I thought they were,
uh, I thought they were really funny.
Um, oh, here's another one.
Here's another one.
Uh, this one.
This is another, uh, another concept GUI that we had.
Obviously, it got scrapped because the actual one looks a
lot better.
other uh concept art we had going into this and oh here we
go okay i found i found it i found some of the logos and
stuff um there's another logo that we went in um so here's
more like logo concepts and everything uh let's see i'm
trying to i'm scrolling guys guys i know i'm scrolling we're
at 22 Guys, we're getting there.
Oh my god, we're at 22.
Halfway there.
We're halfway there.
Holy shit.
Oh yeah.
You guys might not have seen this.
This is also a blink and you miss it moment type deal.
But here.
So this was the cork board.
Of behind us during the...
uh but what's the word um journey animation so this was like
the dragoons like board in the background so like uh you see
like you know their vacation photos and then you guys trying
to draw draw anime
yes uh oh my god oh my god okay okay there was i was looking
through chat messages I was looking through the chat
messages and I was like I need Thomas Edison on my friends
list because he's my oh she and then someone in the chat was
like are we talking we're talking about this Thomas Edison
right like and then and then they're like are we talking
about this Thomas Edison like and then they link the picture
of Thomas Edison like there's there's we're not talking
about something else right this Thomas Edison right
Link the picture of Thomas Edison Like I know it's confusing
for those who didn't watch the climbing stream And you're
gonna be like Okay like Like she's not fucking with us right
Like that Is there like something I should know Regarding
Thomas Edison Like is there somebody else?
Like okay When I say like Okay if you heard this with no
contest And I'd be like is my oh she like oh you'd be
confused like it's understandable it's understandable why
they were they were so confused as to like what the fuck is
she talking about why does she want thomas edison in her
game um anyway so we also had oh yeah retro dokey this was a
retro dokey's original retro retro retro dokey original like
uh polygon model um I didn't like the hat being like so we
changed that.
So this was the original hat of it.
And then we changed it to something like, I didn't explain.
Okay, I was like, he's my Oshi.
That's all I need to explain.
That's all I need to say is my Oshi.
You don't explain your Oshis.
Like, it's just your Oshi.
anyway and then this is what it um um this is what it ended
up look like uh look like because like i said like i didn't
like how the hat protrude a lot so i requested that to be
changed i was like no i want the hat to look like that all
right i'm scrolling we are at page 26 now.
Guys, we're almost there.
We're so close.
I'm looking through.
If there's, like, anything, like...
If we do make an... Oh, look.
Oh, my God.
This is so cute, though.
But, uh... This is so cute, but look at this.
Look at retro polygon.
Um... Look at this.
Oh, my God.
This is so cute.
I actually really...
Oh, my gosh.
I actually really like retro polygon, dokey.
What the fuck?
This is so cute.
I didn't why I didn't even see this I was so busy I didn't
even I didn't even see this oh my god oh sorry the staff
team really wanted me to show you guys this but they in
unintentionally made a dick um you guys might be like what
does that mean okay so like if I get if YouTube takes this
down you know why uh I'm gonna risk it I'm so this is what
the map looked like and they accidentally They zoomed out
and they realized they accidentally made this
They're like oh my god I zoomed out like what the fuck what
wait wait when did this happen What did this happen?
But this is in this is in the map somehow.
I don't know if it's still in it, but this was what it what
it was there also here's a scrapped horror at first before
before we had duck by daylight we had we had this i don't
know what the parody was honestly but this was like a horror
game icon parody of like the rabbits sewn together uh so
this was like one of the parodies that we had um let's see i
wonder if i sent you my big please respond thank you for the
super chat no Thank you.
When I say there's anything else that I want to show you
guys, there's anything.
Oh, yeah.
I wonder if we guys saw...
I feel like...
No, I've shown some of these before.
Um...
Oh, we're at 33.
Oh, okay.
Here's another thing I wanted to show you guys.
Okay, it's a video.
But it is basically the concept.
I think it was a concept video.
of oh wait before i show you guys this but look at this
though look at this I'm sorry this this was very important
for me to show you
I'm sorry this was important it was so important you don't
understand this is very important anyway what I actually
wanted to show you guys This was the original, um, anime,
uh, the storyboard for, um, how it was going to be the
storyboard of, like, everything.
So, like, how this was all going to be done and everything.
So you can see game, company name, Lamau, gang name.
original game theme plays but yes this is like locked out or
everything so uh maybe yeah like finding lobby yeah so i'll
show you guys this while i look through more concept
um i've already seen it so like i don't have to i can
multitask and look through this real fast um but yeah that
was the original concept video of like blocking everything
out for everybody so they know exactly like okay what we
sort of need to do and like um what uh what must be done
like what kind of gui we have to do what kind of uh what
kind of um uh i guess like what assets we need materials uh
raggy did the animation uh i believe boldy did the
storyboard like the animation story board um video
storyboard but i have to double check i might be wrong
because i can be wrong
i won't i won't be surprised if i'm wrong i i i'm tired
There's a lot going on that may or may not remember.
Oh, here we go.
I wanted to show you guys this, but this was, like, the
original.
Let's see.
I think this was the original Dokiverse video.
I'm going to double check.
Because, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, this was the original Dokiverse logo, by the way, that
I'm going to show you guys soon.
But, yes.
Here's the storyboard.
Woo!
It looks so good.
I can't believe Raggy did all like she didn't do the
background Um Um, she wanted to but we were like No
Originally she almost decided to do the background Anyway,
this is what the dokeyverse logo was originally going to be
But we changed it because we thought that Um, I don't know,
it looked really plain originally So that's why we changed
the uh which the other one was where it flew in i felt like
the it sliding in just looked way too plain so that's why i
removed it uh to make it so that it actually like uh flew in
and stuff yeah like the fact that she wanted to do all that
herself like originally everything a little crazy
like yes we're all workaholics here but there is like a
stopping point of where you have to just stop.
So, yeah, we did stop her.
We stopped her.
I guess we're like, yeah, that's that's not, that's not
ideal.
It's not ideal at all.
Let me see if there's anything else that I really want to
showcase you guys.
Oh, here.
Look at him.
Look at this big boy.
We're going to call it ended here, guys.
Look at this big boy whoa next thing thank you for super
chat thank you thank you imagine wanting to do everything
yourself couldn't be dokey thank you for super chat thank
you thank you i'm slowly learning how to delegate though for
real i'm slowly learning how to uh delegate to my staff
members to help me on stuff because like i am definitely
stretching myself in on a lot of things and um i've been
noticing that and because I want to do so many things but
then I realized that's too many things so I'm slowly
learning how to delegate and getting my staff members more
involved in some of my work um and it's been a huge journey
um oh yes the orchestra so like I um yes okay so the reason
why I hired this person I had four different composers
because I I wanted to like work with a lot of different
composers just because um I think music I feel like I wanted
I wanted more connections within the music um industry okay
I don't know industry I guess like within the music areas in
v-tubing because I feel like that's something I heavily
lacked in terms of connections and like I don't really know
like much about music in general um so that's why like I
hired four different composers because I want to see like
how these four different composers um handle my what I want
like my music requests um just so like I realize like uh
what it and you know I can always have uh I can use the
music for anything in the future and everything so um one of
them was a composer I didn't think he was gonna actually
hire a real orchestra um in the beginning because I just
wanted like you know I thought he was just I originally I
was like oh maybe I didn't realize it was like an actual
orchestra equestria I thought he did it all in his program
and later he was like do you want me to hire an orchestra I
was like that's a lot of money I was just like I don't know
man that's a lot of money and and then he was like no it's
okay I have actually have a second booking use this
orchestra for another client um and like um we can use uh
that booking to also do the songs to the song and then i was
like and he'll be like it'll be cheaper and i was like and
then i heard it'll be cheaper so then i was like okay i did
not realize what orchestra he hired by okay i don't know
when i saw the invoice by the way i need to pay the invoice
by the way i need to pay the invoice but like when i saw the
invoice for it he also did like three tracks but like when i
saw the invoice i was like this is cheaper
i didn't i saw it i was like this is cheaper i didn't i
didn't know oh my god
even paid the full fucking price for the orchestra
apparently i got the cheaper version because i was mooching
off somebody else's like booking i was i was mooching up
someone else's like his another client's booking up the
orchestra so we technically split the cost for the orchestra
so i was like holy that was cheaper
Oh my god I was equally as shocked Because I didn't realize
Also I didn't realize this orchestra Played for like Famous
movies and video games I thought he was just gonna hire Some
fucking random orchestra Not some fucking Oscar Winning
fucking orchestra
I didn't know But it was worth it.
It was so cool.
It was it was it was really cool though in the end I I saw
the video and I was like Jesus Christ.
Okay Oh Yeah, it's the it's the Budapest Orchestra I was
like I was also like no way But you guys when you guys all
saw the video I saw the video for the first time, too
Oh my god, even I was like, no fucking way Holy shit, it was
insane I was like, I'm insane
Oh my god Oh, I used, I didn't use the battle theme Because
that was a battle theme that he gave me I used the, he made
a happy theme that wasn't shown in the video there was a
happy theme there's a chill theme and there's a battle theme
I used a happy theme in the debut um but yeah that shit was
insane that shit was intense oh my god it was crazy amazing
I was so surprised like it was so cool watching an actual
orchestra play like something I commissioned um but yeah
huge shout out to that guy for making that possible like I
said I commissioned him because I saw that he does like
orchestra arrangements and I didn't realize there were
actual real orchestra arrangements when until he like told
me in a DM I was like you know what and then he was like oh
but it'll be cheaper because we're gonna split a cost of
another client and I was like oh it'll be cheaper okay then
I'll I'll take it I'll do it you know fuck it I'll do it and
I didn't realize and I looked at the invoice I was like that
was cheaper
I just it still blows my mind I'm like I like look at the
invoice like that's cheaper many they give us super chat
thank you thank you we need as a bgm to get as much mileage
as you can oh my god but yeah oh my god that that that that
shit was it insane it was so cool it was actually so fucking
cool um i oh my i you know words can actually describe how i
feel about the orchestra because when i watched the video i
was like oh my god this is beautiful i was like i'm real
orchestra an orchestra that has played okay all right like
it actually played for like genshin impact dude i was like
what the fuck it it's done like okay it's okay i need to
look at like guys what has it done weak wikipedia all right
it's done so much shit i i don't even know I don't even know
I just know it's done like A lot of movies and games I know
it did like orchestra Like songs for Genshin Impact too It
did Skyrim It did fucking Skyrim Oh my god It played music
for Skyrim Oh my god And everything But yeah Alright that's
all I want to say The entire fear in South Bro, oh my god,
put my name in that Wikipedia for their resume It also did a
song for Doki Bird, a random VTube indie VTube
It did a song for a random indie Vtuber too, by the way
Anyway, off to my next stream, guys I'm going to call it
here, I need at least like 10 minutes of rest before i get
into my next stream um i hope you guys enjoyed the behind
the scenes i'll talk to the project team if they're open
willing to make an art book out of this um anyway as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and learn
around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me
uh maybe stay up for a little bit longer because we're
playing apex next anyway guys see you guys next time or next
stream bye everybody bye